If everyone in your entire high school
suddenly turned into flesh eating zombies,
what would you do?
The world is, you know,
it has been infected by a deadly virus
and nowhere is safe.
I'm going to break down the mistakes made.
What you should do and how to beat the
undead zombies in high school of the dead.
All these hopeful kids with bright
futures are about to die.
Takashi, here is your every day
high school student
who is sulking the day away
by getting some peace and quiet.
Little does he know that his reality
is about to change for the worse.
He soaks around some more
and while leaning off the school balcony,
suddenly see something
super strange at the school gates.
It's a person, but something is not right,
and they're acting strange.
Takashi then spots some school teachers
confronting the strange man at the gate,
when all of a sudden
this strange man tears
the teacher's flesh right in front of him,
the bitten man screams and collapses
and the other teachers stare in shock.
Then all of a sudden
he sees the teacher get back up and bite
another one of the teachers, Takashi's
eyes bulge as he runs off knowing what
we know that everyone here is about
to turn into flesh eating zombies.
Well, I certainly hope
that Takashi is a fan of the movies,
because if this goes anything
like a normal zombie movie or TV show,
then Takashi would be questioning
what he saw for half the film
and wouldn't have used the word zombie
until the very end of the show, if ever.
Just like some other zombie
TV shows that I won't mention,
but the fact of the matter is
is that the concept of the undead
since its resurgence
from its possible ancient Greek origin
has been around since zombie lover George
Romero popularized it in the 1968
film Night of the Living Dead.
And since then,
there has been at least 7900 films
not including TV shows,
meaning that at this point in time,
knowing the traits, habits
and weaknesses of a zombie
is too ingrained in our pop culture
to not know a zombie when you see one.
And since we know that
what we're seeing is a zombie,
I wouldn't hesitate to stop the outbreak
before telling anyone else you're welcome.
Now, from the looks of things
that zombie by the gate was slow
I got because we're no Brad Pitt.
We're better,
which means
that we could have had enough time
to run downstairs to the kitchen cafeteria
or grab a chair and a knife
before pulling up at the gate
to kill the one or two
freshly baked out of the oven zombies
before they had the chance to spread
the infection even further in the school.
If Takashi knows what's good for him,
he should put a stop to this before shit
hits the fan and preparing for the
incoming zombie pandemic before shit hits.
The fan is the exact reason
why your love state of survival.
Our sponsor for today's video
data survival is a zombie
themed survival strategy mobile game
that is both available on Apple and Google
App Stores,
a game that begins with a firm
financial foundation known as Giga Corp,
which just finishes building a deadly
weapon, releasing chaos across the world,
and you, as a survivor
are expected to rebuild your last home,
as well as fight off countless zombies
and finding the man responsible
for all this, the man known as Klein.
Beginning on 25th November
through January will be
when there's a limited time
crossover event begins starring a hero,
or should we say, anti-hero
the Joker himself?
And this includes customized weapons
skills, as well as a customized storyline
unique to the Joker himself,
with funding, gameplay
and in-game events
such as the Arena of Doom,
where players will compete against
laughing zombies,
a new type of zombie,
as well as other players
have you saving folks, building defenses
and fighting off zombies left and right,
like in the Explorer trailer,
which will have you explore
unknown areas whilst fighting off
waves of different zombies.
With multiple game modes
available for PvP PvP,
as well as KvK download state of survival.
Now using the link below to experience
this limited time crossover event
and use my creative code feedback S.O.S.
to redeem an in-game
starter pack containing three profile
caps, one epic search map, 50,000 Food
Water Medal, 1000 Cheap XP
and the rare hero rusty himself.
But the number of starter packs
is limited to first come,
first serve, as well as 10 x 50 dollar
Amazon gift cards for new players.
So download my link and reach Level six.
Thank you to state of survival
for sponsoring this video
and now back to the show.
Takashi then bust into the classroom
and grabs a hold of his childhood friend
Rei, saying that people
are being killed outside
and that they need to get out of here.
This grabs
the attention of Takashi friends nearby,
including his best friend Hisashi.
The gang runs out of the classroom
and just then they hear on the intercom
that the school is in a state of emergency
and that violence has erupted
in the school.
Panic and utter chaos takes over
after every single student hears
the terrifying screams of the dying
teacher on the intercom.
Hisashi says that they should head
to the roof and wait for help,
and so they set off encountering a scary
zombie on the way there and realizing
that they're more dangerous than they look
barely escaping with their lives,
but not before
one of them loses their only chance
at survival.
Hisashi has been bitten, and I suppose
you can say he can thank his lucky stars
because they don't know that
certain death awaits him.
Elsewhere, we see countless groups
of people getting killed left and right.
Even best friends back
stabbing each other to survive, showcasing
to us the ultimate savagery
that mankind is capable of reaching.
The roof the gang sees all around them
that the whole of the area
and maybe even
the world has gone into complete chaos
just as more zombies start to surround
that, forcing them to run past the hordes
and barricade themselves up
past this staircase.
But Hisashi is now on the brink of death
and asks Takashi
to kill him as they both know
what will soon happen to him.
All of a sudden, Hisashi
turns into a flesh
eating zombie, forcing Takashi to sack up
and end his best friend's life.
Well, that's not fair.
I just lost the one person
who I know would be a guarantee
to like my next Instagram pick.
But Takashi, what are you doing?
You should have ended your friend's life
before he turned.
Common courtesy healer.
I would have also begun
taking notice of the victims in the school
when we were in the clear,
because the one thing that zombie pop
culture doesn't
guarantee is the incubation period
of a zombie bite before someone turns.
And this is something
that we should work on finding out ASAP.
Because the first bite mark victims
at the school gates turned
almost instantly, whereas my best friend
took his sweet time to die.
If I was Takashi, aside
from making sure that we begin
looking for weapons, I'd also begin
taking notes on the zombie enemy.
I would have also use this time
to examine my friend's dead body.
I would begin looking around his bite mark
to see if there were any telltale signs
of rapid infection or warning
signs laid in on the surface of his skin,
from any rashes to hives to skin disorders
beginning to form around his body
or around the bite mark.
Because we know that this virus
on a molecular level
changes the physical appearance
of a zombie victim,
so we might as well studied
the signs of someone who has been bitten
because the next person who we befriend,
who ends up getting bitten
might not be as honest with us
as our best friend was elsewhere.
The horrifying carnage continues.
While this pink haired girl and glasses
guy have decided to pair off and run
as fast as they can with glasses, guys
saying
that they should head
to the teacher's lounge for help.
But pink haired girl points out
that another group had the same dumb idea
across the top floor.
Back on the school roof,
Rei tries calling her dad, who was a cop
but can't get through to him,
showing that not even the adults, teachers
or even cops can save them now.
Or, dare I say, even the military
at the Medical Bay, blond haired
girl here is trying to grab
the remaining medicine bottles,
but she's too slow and zombies
break through the door.
They savagely tear her friend apart,
ripping into him like a buttery soft
steak, The zombies
then come for blond hair, girl.
Just as this purple haired girl, captain
of the kendo club, busts in and saves her
just as more zombies burst into the room.
Meanwhile, in the science lab,
pink haired girl and glasses guy
try to find some makeshift weapons to use.
Finding a gas and still to nail gun
right in the nick of time.
The zombies bust down the door,
but not before glasses.
Guy customizes the crap out of his nail
gun and shoots all the zombies,
popping their heads
with some blue collar nails,
and the duo runs off into the hallway
back on the roof.
Takashi and Rei use a fire hose and blow
all of the zombies away.
Now, knowing
that no one is coming to save them
and they decide to head to Takashi House
and after that, to meet up
with any other survivors in the hallway,
pink haired girl makes the most shocking
discovery and notices that all the zombies
are in fact blind, only relying on
sound to hunt for their prey.
This is their weakness.
Glasses Guy begins taking out zombies left
and right just as one creeps up behind
pink haired girl, causing her to fill
the hallways with her terrified screams.
This alerts
the few nearby survivors to her area,
and the friend group increases
by a few more zombie killing students.
Holy crap, Willy Wonka,
this is my golden ticket.
This is priceless information.
By noticing that they rely on sound
to find their prey is enormous.
This changes everything,
and rather than focusing on killing them,
however I can't,
I would begin focusing on collecting small
robot items that we could have used
against the zombies.
Because in theory, if zombies are blind
and only rely on sounds, then
that means we could have simply distracted
most of them using the unimportant
robot items,
which would make a lot of sound
erupt on one side of the room while we run
towards the other side to safety.
They already have makeshift weaponry.
And finally,
before we get out of this school,
we're going to try
to stop at the cafeteria if we can,
assuming that the place is not overrun
because there is probably still food
and even more weapons
that we can stock up on there.
Once that is done, I would use our loud
throw items to distract the zombies away
from the courtyard, allowing us clear
access and escape the school entirely.
The group decides to divide and conquer,
splitting up to kill the horrifying
brain eaters left and right,
killing every single one of them
as the gang familiar rises themselves
with each other and take refuge
in the classroom for the time being.
To assess the situation more thoroughly
and to listen in on the world to news,
they hear on the news that this plague
has taken over the whole world by storm,
meaning nowhere is safe for anybody.
The news advises everyone to stay inside,
but the group suspects
that the news is covering up
the real severity of the situation,
not wanting the world to panic.
The news also says that tactical warheads
will be deployed to help combat
the situation.
The group then decides that
the first order of business is to find out
if their families.
Ah, OK,
then secure a new home
to hold up for a while, teaming up
and using all of their combined skills,
the group heads out of the front door
and take out zombie after zombie
taking brains and taking names.
The gang finally reaches the courtyard,
and they come across some more survivors
deciding to save them as well
and offering them a ride.
Next, stop the bus at the ground floor.
The group stops and reassesses.
It's chaos out there
with zombies everywhere,
meaning the only way they'll get through
is by going through quietly
with gliding feet and light steps.
Takashi creeps around all the zombies
until one of his friends messes up badly.
That's it.
The zombies know where they are.
The group needs to run doing
absolutely everything that they can.
The group finally makes it to the bus,
but not before they lose a member
becoming this school's next
Japanese human sushi snack.
Okay, this Kang is stupid,
but the main kids
seem to have their shit together,
but not everyone else does.
And of course, why would they?
They're all kids.
What Takashi should have done
was to have ordered
smaller groups
made up of two or three people
to head towards the bus, taking turns
to head to the bus in an orderly fashion.
People in smaller groups could have paid
better attention to their partners
and could have helped guide
the ones who were more likely to mess up
having better control in a smaller group
rather than a bigger one.
Yes, the process would have been slower,
but taking a more methodical approach
would have been the smarter thing to do.
Remember, this whole group
is made of a bunch of kids
and we know how kids can be.
Takashi and crew reached the bus, but
the intensity isn't over in the distance.
They see another group of students
led by a teacher, and the gang decides
whether or not they should wait for them.
But this isn't no ordinary group,
and the teacher is more sinister
than he looks.
Leaving behind a desperate classmate
to die to save himself, his group has yet
to realize that this man will cause them
more horrifying troubles in the future.
Barely making it,
everybody finally gets on
as the bus takes off in charges
right out of the front gate of the school.
But the menacing realities of the world
aren't over for them just yet,
because this teacher is more of a freak
than his haircut makes him
look as he tries
to convince everyone on the bus
to make him the leader of the group.
And in the back of the bus,
the class students begin to eat
right out of his hand,
alerting the core group to the dangers
of this man and for what's to come.
OK, while I admit this creepy teacher
is definitely giving off
some strange vibes
and the fact that he wants to be
the leader so badly for seemingly
no apparent reason is majorly suspicious.
From the looks of things, he's
a showman and also a smooth talker
and has a psychopathic vibe
due to his charm and manipulative
nature is already infiltrated himself
as the man for the job
within these gullible teenagers,
especially the ones in the back,
which is a major problem as society
is on the brink of collapse, meaning
social order is one hair away from chaos.
And that means societal
rules aren't as important,
which means we either need to stop him now
or leave this group behind
because the power that he has
when society is done for
will be similar to that of a cult leader,
meaning whatever he says goes
at his followers due to their devotion
to him or do whatever he says at any cost.
I would calmly tell this teacher
to postpone the selection of a leader
for now until we figure out our next move,
or most importantly, have the opportunity
to leave this bus for good or kill him.
This would likely make him a bona fide
martyr at this point,
meaning that his students
would likely wants payback
and would come in the form of sabotage
or backstabbing
at some point in the future,
which we can't afford to have right now,
and we can't have a democracy vote
as his group has seven people
while our group has six,
which means the teacher's class would out
vote us in this instance.
So our only option is to either postpone
the selection of the leader in some way
or killed the teacher.
I would prefer killing him,
but that would mean killing
the rest of the students,
which would not be a great plan.
The creepy teachers antics piss off Rei,
who storms off the bus just as Takashi
tries to get her to come back on board.
But suddenly a massive raging bus comes
hurtling towards them at full speed,
full of undead monsters crashing
right in front of Takashi and Rei,
causing them to barely
get out of there with their lives .
But the tunnel becomes blocked off,
so Takashi says to meet up with them
at the East Police
Station nearby, Takashi and Rei
run off, barely making it out yet again.
After a while,
Takashi manages to steal a bike
while
they drive off to the police station,
driving now through the new wasteland
that is Tokyo city,
with no one living or dead
to greet them on their travels,
even managing
to find a gun for safekeeping,
I would prefer to add a silencer to that,
just saying.
But unfortunately, their luck finally
takes a turn and they run low on gas,
forcing them to head up
the next gas station.
They see Takashi and GRei end up
not having any available cash
nor credit cards to pay for the gas.
So Takashi heads inside the store
to get some juice.
Then he hears the horrifying screams
coming from Rei right outside, forcing
Takashi to run back out to take a look
and he has gRei by the throat.
The gangster forces
Takashi to throw his bad away,
drawing the nearing hordes of zombies
with the sound that comes with it,
and this gangster
makes him fill up the bike with the gas.
Takashi has had enough
and at the last moment
whips out his gun and shoots this guy of.
A pseudo style saving rate
like the stud that he is
and getting the hell out of there,
leaving this loser to his horrifying fate.
OK, well, I do appreciate Takashi
Noble Knight in shining armor nature.
He did not need to run back out of there
as soon as he heard her scream.
Takashi knows Rei well enough that
she would not just scream for no reason,
so he did not need to run out of there
and expose himself like that.
Rushing out of there
put him at a disadvantage.
The better option would have been to go
with the element of surprise,
which would have been way more efficient
and way more quiet.
Takashi already has a gun, meaning
he wouldn't need to close the distance
as much as he would have needed
with an edged weapon.
And if we remember
the bike needed gas to drive,
but the gas tank needed cash
first to allow this, meaning
Takashi could have stayed hidden
within the store
until the gangster
entered the store himself
once the gangster entered the store.
Takashi could have
simply waited for his chance
and put some led right into his brain.
There was no need to rush
and expose himself to the gangster.
Worst case, Rei would have died,
and we still would have gotten off
scot free
with a dead gangster on our hands.
Now driving across the city,
Takashi and Rei witnessed the entire city
going to hell with
living, breathing people and zombies
alike, trying to kill everyone.
No one is safe.
They stop near a bridge out of town,
but it's packed so they decide to head to
an Batsuit bridge.
Another route out of town where they hope
to meet up with the gang back on the bus,
the gang sits in traffic
as the only exits out of the city
are packed with terrified,
frightened people hoping to leave
Tokyo City before it's too late.
Glasses guy talks with pink haired girl
as they discuss where to go.
Mentioning
that they need to cross in Petzel Bridge
and head to the police station.
But they're running out of time
as this teacher
is clearly warping his students minds,
turning half of the group into a cult.
So the main gang leaves the bus
in search of another vehicle,
but on the bridge,
the situation isn't any better.
The gang comes face to face
with terrifying hordes of zombies
encircling the group
and trapping them back on the bike.
However, Takashi and Rei
drive near the bridge and see a truck,
and Takashi uses this moment to pull off.
And can I say a freaking STO move
blasting up the ramp
and launching into the Sky Atlantic
right in front of the group
and managing
to take out a few zombies in the process,
hoping the gang kick zombie butt.
But crossing this bridge isn't that easy,
and crossing through the stream
isn't an option, so blond haired
girl offers her friend's apartment to them
and that she has a key to its nearby,
saying that the gang can go there
and take refuge for a bit.
OK, this blond girl is more silly
than she looks, and that's me being nice.
This is the type of stuff that maybe
you should have brought up in conversation
way earlier.
I mean, come on.
Realistically,
in the event of a zombie apocalypse,
holding up is probably our best option.
In the intermediate term,
a zombie apocalypse would last for far
less than you think.
After all, zombies are practically
walking corpses, which means in theory,
the longer we stay holed up in our houses,
the progressively weaker and weaker
all of these zombies become,
which then would become even easier
for us to kill over the coming days.
The zombies
that wouldn't be killed by wild
animals would eventually succumb
to whether exposure as a zombie
has no instinct to seek shelter, either
freeze or dry out over the coming days.
The smartest thing that we can do
right now is to wait indoors.
Now, of course, this is highly dependent
on the type of shelter we're heading to.
The gang relaxes in the apartment
as the news claims that the situation
is only getting worse, with the virus
now claiming over 2 million victims
with projected amounts to go over
10 million victims within two days,
meaning 10 million more zombies
to deal with the gang needs to prepare for
what's to come.
But luckily, blond haired
girl's friend's place is packing more
than just luxury square footage.
Back on the bridge,
the cops say that they've lost
almost all contacts from upper management,
saying their last order was to do
whatever it takes to hold and claim.
This bridge from the mass
is trying to get through,
even killing someone
and shooting them in the head.
They mean business, and no one is getting
through near the apartment.
The gang spots a father and daughter
as they go house to house,
begging to be let in
and saved from the horrifying hordes
that are closing in on them.
But this is in a civil world anymore,
and nobody trusts anybody.
The dad then bangs and bangs on one door
but suddenly gets stabbed, leaving his
daughter alone to face the horrors
that will soon reach her.
But Glasses Guy has got her in his sights
and fires off a round after round,
picking off the flesh, eating zombies left
and right, alerting
everybody in the apartment.
The horde outside and even this random
dog, which totally throws out their plan
to stay hidden and to not make us sound,
they have a new mission rescue.
That little girl
Takashi heads off on the bike
to save her with glasses
guide covering him from the rooftop,
Takashi dashes
through the zombies
and crashes hard right in front of her.
He quickly kills off the surrounding
zombies, takes
this girl up and heads
for the top of the wall.
Holy crap, this is actually terrifying.
These zombies just came out of nowhere,
and now our nice little spot
is compromised.
Now I'm
not one for showing any acts of decency
because this is the apocalypse people.
But all. Let's talk about this situation
for a sec. one.
He should have brought more
than his revolver, and two,
he should have brought a piece of string
and a coin.
But otherwise Takashi, for one,
has got a huge set of marbles on him.
Because he went in hard
and from the looks of things,
he managed to secure the gate entrance,
which was smart on his end, but he took
a risk in walking in between the wall
when he was carrying that girl.
The zombies could have easily
grabbed onto his foot and made him fall,
which is why I think we should have been
a little more sneaky again.
The zombies have poor to no eyesight,
relying mainly on sound.
He could have used his bike
and if, as in two pieces
of string
along with the coin that we brought
and would have tied it
to the horn button on the motorbike,
this would have allowed the bike
to sound off with its horn,
lowering the zombies away by the noise
and covering any sound that we make.
As we scaled over the wall with the kit
and climbed
in between house to house, slowly
making our way back to our safe house.
Takashi balances his life
and this girl's life on the thin edge wall
as they try to walk back to the apartment.
But the gang waits for no one
and dash into the Hummer
with all of their things and rushed to go
save Takashi, the girl and the dog
driving off to avoid the now
millions of hordes of zombies
alerted to their apartment location
elsewhere up in the sky.
Even the United States
president and his cabinet
have succumbed to the virus, with almost
all of Air Force one now turned undead.
The president has a choice to make
before he dies to enter the code
to launch an attack on the world
before they use intercontinental missiles
to destroy the U.S., activating Triple
six Delta Protocol before everyone dies.
Back in Japan, the gang finally crosses
the river, reaching the other side.
But something isn't right
because there's no one around.
Dead or alive to be seen.
The gang cautiously drives
through the empty streets, finding
not a single soul until a horde of zombies
comes up on the road,
being present around every street.
Their numbers keeps growing
larger and larger
as the gang gets into the city,
forcing the group to drive
right through them, killing
hundreds of them in seconds.
But they suddenly notice a wired fence cut
right through the road, forcing the gang
to make a quick turn and drift near it,
almost running into a wall in the process
and causing Rei to injure herself.
They are now trapped,
with hundreds of zombies closing on them.
Takashi jumps down to save rate and starts
blasting away
the zombies left and right, but
there are way too many for him to control.
So purple haired girl jumps down
to help them out,
killing as many undead as she can.
But they're running out of time,
and they've got to figure out
a better way to handle this
before they die.
This group could have gotten out
from the get go.
It's obvious that the wired fence
is holding off the zombies.
The gang could have jumped over the wired
fence and ran away,
or if they couldn't, for whatever reason,
another method could have been resolved
by taking advantage of their inability
to see and rely on sound.
The gang could have stayed in the Hummer
with Takashi
had someone else to begin
making noise on the opposite
end of the road,
luring the zombies away from the Hummer,
and they would have been blinded to what
was actually going on for the majority.
Staying in the Hummer
would have only given them
temporary protection against the zombies
and would have muffled any sounds that
the gang could have given off, thereby
giving the zombies
a chance to hone in on only one source
of sound being drawn in from that area
by making sure that Takashi
and whoever else is with them,
make the loudest noise possible
to lure the zombies away.
Staying in the Hummer
would have also shield of the gang
from giving off their scent,
which at this moment
is a preventative measure,
since we don't know for sure
if the zombies can smell since up
until now.
This hasn't been established yet,
but I personally am not going to take that
chance.
The gang runs
nearly out of bullets, forcing everyone
to take some drastic, raunchy measures.
Purple haired girl and Takashi
try to lure the zombies
away from the Hummer
by running up the nearby stairs.
But there's too many of them
and they don't budge,
forcing the gang
to use up the rest of their ammo
and they know that
their minutes are numbered,
but that's just
when the most insane thing happens.
Some folks dressed in firefighter
gear show up across the fence
and blast the close
by zombies with pressurized water cannons,
and one of them turns out to be pink
haired.
Girl's mother, Takashi and purple haired
girl make a run for it,
and they plan to meet back with the group
at a later point.
Since Takashi knows where pink her
girl lives, Takashi and purple haired
girl stumble across a bike shop
as they run through the empty streets
and they decide to go
with an amphibious vehicle,
and the duo launches into the river
nearby.
They decide to stay at a nearby temple
right by pink
haired girl's house for the night
because they know
they won't make it to the house in time
because no one sits down at night.
Not anymore.
Takashi and purple haired girl make it
to the temple and rest up for the night.
The next day arrives
as silence fills the empty stone streets.
Takashi opens the temple door,
not knowing what terrors await him
until an entire horde of zombies
climbs up the steps and head
straight for him and purple haired girl.
Somehow,
they knew their location, despite them
not making a single sound
the entire night.
Or did they? They
are in trouble.
For starters,
he should have secured that temple better
and if looked for a back exit,
the second he got there.
And also,
while the zombies can't see properly,
there is still an issue of smell
which we haven't taken into account.
We don't know for sure,
but it's reasonable to assume
that the zombies were led there
by our sense.
Aside from simply going through them,
I would have put our very own samurai
purple hair
to go on for protection duty to guard us,
and I would have gutted a single zombie
before placing their organs and intestines
all over us.
This would have allowed us
to see if by dressing up as a zombie with
the scent
would make the zombies leave us alone.
And if this doesn't work,
we could have simply lured enough of them
around the walkway of the temple.
This way, the zombies could have been.
At around the temple,
which would have cleared
the pathway enough
for us to get out of there,
the duo does their best to break through
with this zombie horde
and run for their lives.
Finally reaching pink hair, two girls
mother's house,
a sprawling compound
filled with other workers
and security for everybody,
including four pink haired girls.
Dad, a hard edged man who is known
as the big boss of the area and
for a brief moment, the gang almost feels
as if things have gone back to normal.
But nothing is built to last,
and the adults in the compound
treat the kids like shit
and boss them around,
treating them like kids
who have now gone
through a zombie apocalypse,
knowing that this type of structure
won't work for long.
The kids get together and decide
if they should get absorbed
by the now large compound group
or should strike out on their own.
But the outside is only getting worse,
with millions of zombies
coming to life every day.
But pink haired girl knowing her terrible
family, thinks that they won't last long.
And here back on the teachers bus.
However, the gang after all
this while has gone absolutely nuts.
Brainwashing all of these teenagers
for the worst
and turning this group
into an unofficial madmen cult.
And they also finally find the same
compounds that Takashi's group is in.
But Takashi has got some other problems
in the compound.
The group realizes that everyone here
is too close minded, and everyone here
doesn't think that the undead zombies
are really zombies.
They think that everything is fine
in the outside world
when in reality it's
the complete opposite.
The compound
somehow thinks that Takashi and his group
are just stupid children carrying weapons
and drunk on power,
and it's only a matter of time
until they get that power
taken away from them. All right,
I hate to be the one to break it
to your kids, but you're all just kids.
If I'm a 17 year old
with self-image problems
and pent up hormones,
I would stop for a moment
to think about the reality
of our situation.
one. Barely a few days has passed
and we've been really, really lucky
in this situation.
The longer we stay out in the open,
the higher risk we have of getting injured
and or killed or turned into a zombie.
And zombies
aren't going to be our only enemy.
There are thousands of anarchist
criminals,
people
who despise the current lawful status quo
and won't hesitate
to take advantage of the fall of society.
They won't hesitate to kill
innocent people and do whatever they want.
It's only a matter of time to one of us
gets killed out there, and as society
falls, the decomposing zombies
will be the least of our problem.
Realistically, I would bite the bullet
and take all the shit
this porta-potty dump of a safe
haven would give us.
As in, I would stay here where it's safe
and not leave this place,
probably as long as I can.
Takashi then goes to pink hair girls
dad and says that Rei's dad is a cop
so he can find out what's going on
if he heads to the nearby police station
at, as well as find
her mother in the process too.
But pink haired girls dad says that
in less than two days, the entire compound
will leave this area that the city is far
too dangerous to stay in for much longer.
But Takashi says that
he'll be back before they go,
and if he doesn't, will,
then that probably means
that something happened to him later
as he prepares to leave.
Purple haired girl offers
to keep him company with her
charms and her sword,
and just then they meet a familiar face.
Their old teacher,
but right, isn't having any of his shit
and sticks him up at gunpoint
and forcing him
and his crazy colt to leave the compound
before something happens to him .
The blond haired girl also finally manages
to remember her friend's phone number,
the friend whose apartment they stay at
I had earlier.
She picks up and reunites
with blond haired girl for a brief
second on the phone.
However, elsewhere
hidden in the depths of the ocean,
a submarine gets word
of the executive order given by Air Force
one and the submarine launches
a Trident warhead into the sky.
The warhead blasts right over
Tokyo and cuts blond haired girl's phone
line, along with all other electronics
over the area, cutting off everyone
from everything.
And at the same time, this explosion cuts
off the electronic breaks of the school
teachers bus, causing him to crash
right into the wall of the compound,
unleashing the dead and killing everyone.
Holy shit, this is insane.
Everything and everyone just got hit with
what looks like an empty blast,
which is an electromagnetic pulse
that can temporarily or permanently damage
electronics by generating high voltage
and high currents surges.
Despite conventional wisdom,
according to life wire,
it is unlikely that the majority of cars,
even today, would suffer any long term
permanent damage,
although at this rate,
we don't have time to sit and wait around
and people are panicking,
which means we could have used this
situation to take advantage of everyone.
We don't have enough bullets
to kill every single zombie,
but we do have some bait tons
and tons of bait.
I'd say, excuse me,
thank you, ma'am, and lobbed
some grenades over the resting crowds
nearby, killing everyone. Oops.
But by doing this, I would use their very
bloody body parts as a meaty distraction
to lure the zombies
in while I slip away at the back,
but not before heading into the estate
kitchen.
Inside, I'm going to grab more supplies,
more food and more knives,
and I'm going to leave this
hellhole forever.
Hundreds of people start to panic as
the compound's people and the kids barely
managed to hold it together, slicing off
zombie heads and limbs like its butter.
But everyone knows
that this won't last long,
as thousands more undead
swarmed the compound.
So pink haired girls
dead orders everyone to take his copper
plated anti EMP vehicle, with him
opting to stay behind with his people
and his wife
to hold back the undead to long enough
for the high school group of.
Teenagers to get out of there
and head off into the distance
living, get another day in this new world
filled with the undead.
And if you want to live another day
in a zombie wasteland Don't forget
to like, subscribe, comment and check out
our how to be playlist and below peace.